the other thing we noticed about the two
of you because we there are pictures of
you doing a red carpet together in the
various films done and it's actually you
a very different red carpet approaches
approaches so here's a picture the two
of you on the red carpet looking very
debonair and studied and then you Irene
carpet does it decide you absolutely
bonkers I mean it was Will Ferrell and
his lovely wife there on the red carpet
looking perfectly Pleasant and then
right behind them
[Laughter]
[Applause]
accordingly people do you know is he new
stars new stars just just coming
blinking into the spotlight just got me
to awards season finally this is my
moment here it's Lupita Nyong'o 18 red
carpets by the time we were on that one
she was relieved you know the red carpet
thing no bit like mr. grant we've got a
look have you got a you I'm attempting
something okay try it try it Internet
into 5 they're fine okay so Luke Luke
Luke over here Luke smolder smolder
oh my god oh my god and then was sicker
than any man I've ever seen in my life I
realized I
[Music]